NAZMUL IDRIS: Welcome
to this episode of UXD
where we will talk about
what user research is,
and how you can use it to make
better products that users
will actually want to use.
I'm your host, Nazmul
Idris-- developer, advocate,
passionate about
design and mobile.
And I have a very special
guest with me today.
RICHARD FULCHER: Hi,
I'm Rich Fulcher.
I'm a designer and manager
on the Android team.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Thank
you for being here.
RICHARD FULCHER: Thanks.
NAZMUL IDRIS: So, Rich, from
your personal experience
as a designer, why is user
research important to building
great products?
RICHARD FULCHER:
Well, I've always
been able to benefit from user
research throughout my career.
I feel that it just helps bring
me closer to the people who
are actually going to use the
products that I, and my teams,
helped to design and build.
And that's been true for me
at a big company like Google,
where we have a
large research staff.
It's also been true for a much,
much, much smaller companies
that I've been a
part of as well.
Thinking back to my very
earliest days as a designer,
and my first class in was called
Human Computer Interaction,
back in the day.
That very first class,
we talked about that this
is the study of users, in a
context, making use of tools,
to perform tasks, to
achieve their goals.
So those five important things--
users, context, tools, task,
goals-- are really what
research helps us speak to.
As a designer, I have
a lot of responsibility
in defining the tool.
What does your
program look like?
How does it work?
And I get a little bit of
influence over the task.
What are the steps
that I put you through?
Or how is it divided out
into different pieces?
Research tells me a lot
about those other three
areas as well.
So it tells me about the
users, a little bit more
about who they are.
It tells me about the context
that they use these products
in.
And that's both environments
and just state of mind.
A lot of different factors
come into play there.
And, importantly, it tells
me about their goals.
Not just, get this
thing done, but why
do they want to get
that thing done?
What are they trying to
achieve in their lives, is
the reason for this product.
RICHARD FULCHER:
So, Nazmul, what
do you think of when you
hear the term user research?
What's the picture in your head?
NAZMUL IDRIS: I think
about a lab in an office.
I think about being part
of a usability study,
where other people
watch me actually
use a product that's
already been built,
to see whether it makes
sense to me or not.
Is that right?
RICHARD FULCHER: It sounds like
you're describing that scene
in "Ghostbusters" where Dr.
Venkman has the students come
into his lab in the University,
and does an ESP test,
and electroshocks a few of them.
But that is basically right.
That's one form of testing.
That's what we would
call usability testing,
or in-lab usability studies.
And that's a very common type.
And it's probably the
one that most people
think of as research
when we think
of that in a canonical form.
Those focus on tools and tasks
that we just talked about.
So there's a tool there.
We're asking, can the user use
this tool to complete the task?
We give the user the task
when they step into the lab,
and we just see, well, did
they do it successfully?
If they did, how long did
it take them to do it?
So time on task and
test completion.
But there's a lot more that we
can do in research than just
that.
It's not just testing
that's really important
to remind people about.
The broader goal is bigger
than just validating,
is this product working or not?
What you want to
get out of research
is a richer understanding
about all of your users.
You want to understand
their perceptions
and their expectations.
You want to get
insight about them
that you can apply, not
just for this one thing
that you're testing
right here now,
but that you can apply to all
the future things you might
build for users.
I mean, the next
version of the product,
or a new product that relates
to that same audience.
NAZMUL IDRIS: So,
now, that's starting
to sound a little bit
like market research.
Is that right?
RICHARD FULCHER: It's
definitely related.
There's definitely some overlap
between those disciplines.
Certainly at how they conduct--
set up experiments, or do
data analysis--
there's certainly
common elements there.
I think, about research,
market research
can focus on demographic
or marketing data.
And that's a little bit more
divorced from tasking goals,
but can still speak
to user in context.
It may be things like purchasing
behavior that tie into that.
But user research, I think,
is a little bit more focused
on users' day to day behavior.
What does the user want?
What do they need?
What are those big
capital G goals
that we talked about earlier?
How did the different
contexts affect their ability
to use a product?
If I've got a phone, and I'm
just using it two-handed,
that's a different context than
if I have a latte in one hand,
and I'm one-handing
the phone, and I'm also
running to catch a bus.
It might be the same product.
It might be the same
tasks-- same tools,
same tasks, same goals even.
But the context is
going to make that
a very different
experience for the user.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Exactly.
In fact, we have an episode
dedicated just to context.
RICHARD FULCHER: Oh, perfect.
NAZMUL IDRIS: And it's
going to air soon.
RICHARD FULCHER: Great.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Cool.
So now, those seem like
really big questions.
So how do you even ask
users those questions?
RICHARD FULCHER: Those
are huge questions.
And you're not going to be
able to answer all of them
in an in-lab study, just
with usability testing.
NAZMUL IDRIS: And
that makes sense.
So is this where the expertise
of user researchers come in?
RICHARD FULCHER:
Yeah, absolutely.
On the surface, what a
researcher does sometimes
seems simple.
It's just asking
people questions.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Well,
I can do that.
RICHARD FULCHER:
Everybody can do that.
We can all be journalists.
It's all simple.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Right.
Of course.
RICHARD FULCHER:
It's the same thing
that designers grapple
with sometimes.
Oh, so you draw pictures.
Well everybody
can draw pictures.
NAZMUL IDRIS: I scribble
and I'm a designer.
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah.
I think, in both
cases, that just
belies the rich
set of skills that
an experienced practitioner
can bring to bear.
And for researchers,
they are particularly
expert at figuring
out how to get answers
to difficult questions.
So interviewing-- just flat-out
asking somebody a question--
is one technique
that they'll use.
But it is really
just one of many.
A lot of the techniques
rely on conservation,
as opposed to
direct questioning.
So that it may be going to a
user's home, into a workplace.
It may be bringing
them into a lab,
but not directly prompting
them to do certain things,
and just seeing how they behave.
NAZMUL IDRIS: It's like watching
them in their native habitat.
RICHARD FULCHER: Exactly.
There is an
anthropological aspect
to this that is part
of the discipline.
And researchers compliment that
with a whole bunch of skills.
One is in just
experimental design.
How do I set up a study to find
the answer to this question?
How do I pick which
participants I
should be bringing
in to answer this?
How do I mitigate the bias based
on this artificial situation
I'm putting them in?
Or based on which
users I select.
How do I analyze the
data and collect it?
And then once I've gotten
those findings together,
how do I actually bring
those back to my team,
to my designers,
to my engineers,
and really convince them of the
importance of these findings.
And those are all
critical skills
that a really good
researcher can bring to bear.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That makes sense.
Sounds like researchers
are awesome,
and they should be an
integral part of every team.
RICHARD FULCHER: Definitely.
Throughout my career, which is
[INTENTIONALLY MUMBLES] years
back, I've been most
proud of products
that I've shipped where
design and research have
had a really strong
collaboration.
One just makes the other better.
When you have a designer who
really gets research and is
an active participant
in that process,
whether they're helping
to set up the experiment
or they're taking notes, or
capturing video, or building
a prototype, they
just get more and more
of that immediate information
by being involved, instead of
just waiting for the
findings of the report.
And seeing things
firsthand is always
more powerful than just reading
about it after the fact.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That makes sense.
It puts a human context to it.
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah.
And it's definitely the kind
of thing that, as a designer,
I will be working on something,
and I will think back
to a very particular
experience I had of that.
Oh, I remember when
this user came in,
and they did this thing
that surprised me.
And I definitely
dropped on that.
Likewise, a really
great researcher
will have a good understanding
of the design process.
And they'll be really expert
at thinking about, well,
if this is the
process, I know how
to plug in here or here or here.
And I know for each of those
opportunities what method
is the right one
that I should employ.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Cool.
So now, speaking of plugging
into the process, what
other ways have you
seen research conducted
at different parts of the
product development life cycle?
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah.
So this probably is a topic
that deserves it's own episode.
But at a really
high level, I think,
when you're starting
out on a project,
you want to go out
and observe users
in their natural environment.
The kind of things that
you're looking for here
are to challenge the assumptions
that you may already have.
So you may think users
do this one thing.
But by observing them you
see, OK, they do do that.
But they also do
this other thing.
Or they do this thing in
a slightly different way
than I thought they would.
So those little
surprising insights
can be really valuable.
And they may even shift the
direction of your product
as you see those.
You can also just learn
about what already exists.
So you could look at other
studies that you've done,
or that are published in
the academic literature,
and things like that.
You're asking this question,
what's already been done?
But, really, the
second order question
is, well, how did that work
out when people did that?
So a little bit of that is
competitive evaluation--
looking at other applications.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That makes sense.
So is this like testing
a competitor's product
before actually
building your own?
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah.
And I think a lot of
us do that already.
People that are really
involved with technology,
we just to do this
casually as a user.
I mean, we use lots
of different products.
And there's a lot of
input coming to us
from just our day
to day behavior.
And when we're
thinking about an area,
sometimes it's because we've
used something similar,
or maybe we've used something
that isn't satisfying for us.
And we know we think
we can do something
interesting or
different in that space.
This is just taking that natural
instinct to go and learn,
and making it a little
bit more rigorous.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That makes sense.
So now, after you've
gotten started,
and you've chosen a
direction, and are actively
doing development,
how does research
come into play at that point?
RICHARD FULCHER: Well,
I think research is best
served when it's just
as iterative as the rest
of your development process.
So as early as you
can, you should
get users to play with some
version of your product.
And that could be a
working prototype.
It could be just a
bunch of screenshots
that have maybe been
linked together.
It could just be
pieces of paper.
I've definitely done all
of these forms of testing,
where, for the paper, you get
to play the computer and shuffle
around the different screens
and things like that.
You're just trying to learn,
what's clicking for the user.
What isn't clicking that I
can come back to and iterate,
iterate, iterate.
This is a mantra you'll hear
probably a lot on this show.
Make mistakes early so
you can get over them,
and make things better
in the next one.
You can also just use this
to address any questions that
come up during the course
of building the product out.
There's almost always
some kind of technique
that you can use to help
answer that question,
even if it can't
answer it fully.
If you're being forced to make
a compromise on the product--
NAZMUL IDRIS: Yeah.
That never happens.
RICHARD FULCHER: Never.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Yeah.
I've never heard
of that, actually.
RICHARD FULCHER: Nope.
Being able to draw upon
research to help you resolve
how to best make that
set of trade-offs
is something that can
be really helpful.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Yeah.
No, that's true.
So now, as you get closer to
the end of this development life
cycle, and you're about
to release a product,
how does research
come into play here?
I mean, is this where
usability testing comes in?
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah.
It's definitely the
most typical time
that you'll see in-lab testing.
So you get the
working product there.
The kind of things
you're doing, I think,
best serving at that point are
you're catching final bugs.
You're trying to
identify, am I really
ready to launch this thing?
And, in particular, I think it
identifies the types of bugs
that maybe your
own team has just
habituated itself
to and overcome.
And so it might be
problems with the first use
experience for
somebody who hasn't
been using every
version of the product
you've worked on for
the last three months.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Right.
Because you're
biased, obviously.
RICHARD FULCHER: Absolutely.
You carry a ton of bias,
just from your experience.
But you should be kept
really apprehensive
if this is the first
part of research
that you're doing at this point.
Changes that you make here
are really expensive in terms
of time, of resource, of
possibly delaying your launch.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That's why
iterating is so important.
RICHARD FULCHER: That's
why it's important.
And this is-- don't
just wait till the end,
and don't just do
validation testing.
Understand your users much,
much earlier whenever you can.
And then when you're
at the end-- of course,
launching isn't
really the end-- once
you get the product
launch, you can
observe how live users use
the product in the wild.
Not just, how does somebody use
it two minutes after they've
been introduced, but two
days later, two weeks,
two months later.
And how does that change.
What do they need?
What do they want?
What don't they use?
So you can look at logs.
You can look at comments
on the Play Store.
You can start at this
point thinking about,
well, what's that
next release like?
What's really, really critical
that I need to have in there
because it's still
missing this for users.
What did I think was going to
be a big thing that I was going
to do more work on, but now it's
just not important to users.
So maybe I'd pull
back from that.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Exactly.
Yeah.
I know because it's not
like your application is
ever finished.
Just because you've
launched a current version
doesn't mean you're
going to not do upgrades
and doesn't mean there's not
going to be another version.
So it never really ends.
RICHARD FULCHER: No.
No, your work is never done.
NAZMUL IDRIS: If you do
it right, it never ends.
RICHARD FULCHER: That's right.
That's the positive
way to think about it.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Exactly.
So what are some things
that designers in particular
are looking to get
out of user research?
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah.
I mean, for me it's
always just great
to hear users talk in
their own language,
and just pay attention to
the particular vocabulary
that a user makes use of when
going through your product.
Or even separate
from your product,
when just doing their
task without it.
You can take that
language, and you
can borrow it, and
include it into the UI.
So that might be how
you label an action,
or what you choose
to depict as an icon.
Or things like that.
It just reduces the
need for the user
to translate between their
world and your world.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Yeah.
It reduces the cognitive load,
and it makes it more intuitive.
RICHARD FULCHER: Yes.
And I think that's a lot of
what intuitive, to a user,
means is it's familiar to me.
Either because it's
in the language
I understand, or it's doing
things that I expect it to do,
based on other context.
I think that's what
intuition is for users.
An example might be, if the
users might use the word,
settings, you might want to
use the word, preference,
because you think it's
more correct in some form.
But if that's not the
language the user uses,
they have to do the translation
work to come to your product.
You can, instead,
do the design work
to bring the product closer
to what the user understands,
and just spare them that effort.
And the last thing
about language
is it can also be
a bit of a doorway
into understanding the
users thought process.
So if you talk to a designer for
more than two or three minutes,
you're going to hear the
phrase, mental model.
And there.
I've got it in.
So I earned my badge.
We'd love to talk about that.
All that really means is how
the user understands a process
to work in the world.
And I've seen users
construct both vastly simpler
mental models than
the real model,
and much, much, much more
complicated things as well.
So one example is
for a mobile device.
Battery usage.
I see users in
research who engage
in all kinds of bizarre,
ritualistic behaviors
because they have a
mental model that says,
if I do these things, I will
get more battery or life.
So they swipe away
recent applications
that they're not using.
Or they--
NAZMUL IDRIS: I do that.
RICHARD FULCHER: You
do-- well, there.
Now I've taught you something.
It's all even.
Or they put the device
in airplane mode.
And, of course, as
they're doing all of this,
they're driving the screen
at the highest brightness
and keeping the display active.
And, actually, possibly being
contrary to their goals.
Because the mental model
doesn't match the real model.
And when there is
that mismatch, I
get very excited as a
designer because that's
a huge opportunity.
NAZMUL IDRIS: No.
That makes sense.
RICHARD FULCHER: Once I see,
oh, the user doesn't understand
this, but if they
could understand it,
they would be more effective.
Or their battery would last
longer, or things like that.
So those points of difference
are really interesting.
NAZMUL IDRIS: No.
Definitely another
example of this point
is the refresh
button, where folks
that are not familiar
with, basically,
data being pushed
directly into the device,
might think that, oh,
there's no refresh button.
So the data that
they're seeing is stale.
But, actually, it's being
updated in real time.
And they just don't have
an awareness of that.
And then that can actually be
contrary to their perception
and expectation
from the software.
It feels like, oh,
it's not performing
as well as it should because it
doesn't have a refresh button.
But, in reality, it
is performing well
because it doesn't
have a refresh button.
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah.
We try to be really
careful as designers
not to create the opportunity
for false rituals.
Like by removing a
refresh button that
doesn't do anything, I'm
hopefully moving a user
away from just doing
things to no benefit,
or to no end result.
And, ideally, I'm
freeing up space
to take a meaningless
action away, and put
a meaningful action
in its place.
Because I only
have so much space
to put all of these
actions anyway.
And the more actions I put, the
less emphasis any one of them
gets.
So, yes.
This is very much what
I do on a daily basis.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That's fantastic.
So how does user research
help other folks in a team?
Because we've talked about
the benefits to the designers.
What about benefits to
PMs-- product managers--
and also engineers?
RICHARD FULCHER:
I think everything
you do to better understand
your users can help.
And I'm saying help.
That's not the same as,
make your job easier.
Because sometimes it's very easy
to make an ignorant decision
without knowledge of your users.
Research often will reveal that
there's a lot more variability
in your audience than
you probably had in mind.
And that can complicate some
of your decision making.
NAZMUL IDRIS: So this is kind
of like how user research allows
us to-- it's like
we get to create
our own mental models
off actual users.
And our mental models
might be overly simplistic,
and not actually match the
reality of our actual users.
RICHARD FULCHER:
That's exactly right.
I mean, the mental
model we may have
may be just loaded
with our own biases.
In a lot of ways, that mental
model of who the user is
could just be, well, they're me.
Because I know that person best.
And I want to use this product.
So I'm obviously the user.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Everyone
is just like me.
RICHARD FULCHER:
That's not true at all.
So by doing research,
you can help
release yourself, and
release the rest of the team
from those types of
biases, and getting away
from that monolithic
model of, the user is me.
This is also helpful
in making some
of the debates
about the decision
and those compromises
less confrontational.
Because you're not talking
about, I want this,
and you want that.
It's, our users are
telling us this.
NAZMUL IDRIS: We're
advocates for the user.
They're the stakeholders.
Not us.
RICHARD FULCHER:
And that doesn't
mean the answer is obvious.
But at least we can
engage in an honest debate
about the right way
to try to satisfy
a goal that we agree on.
And when you have
research, you can
talk about what you've observed.
You can think back to that user,
and tell that little anecdote
about, well, that might be true
for you, but I saw this user.
And they did this thing,
which surprised me.
But they did it.
There was a trick I learned
from a colleague long ago,
which is to be very
conscientious about that bias
by just repeating the
word, I, when you're
speaking about
your own opinions.
So if I say, well,
I-I-I think the product
should work this way.
Just saying it three
times, it makes it clear
that-- which is
important, especially
for a designer--
that's me talking.
Not me speaking on
behalf of the users.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Definitely.
You're signaling
to your colleagues
that this is your
own personal opinion.
So they can treat it
with whatever bias--
I mean, look at it
with bias that's built
into that statement.
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah.
And I think it's
helpful for others,
but it's also just
helpful for me.
Because that ritual
that I have of doing,
I-I-I, is there to remind me
that this is what I'm thinking,
not what others have
shown me from research.
NAZMUL IDRIS: No.
That makes sense.
So that's all the time
we have for this episode.
RICHARD FULCHER: Ah.
NAZMUL IDRIS: I know.
Thank you so much
for being here, Rich.
We will do many more episodes
on the topic of user research
very soon.
RICHARD FULCHER: Great.
Well, thanks for having me.
It's been a pleasure.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Absolutely.
And if you haven't already,
please be sure to join our UX
community on Google+.
It's a place where you can
continue this discussion.
And you can meet others who
are just as passionate about UX
as you are.
Thank you very much,
and have a great day.
Goodbye.